[Music]
us
is jordan peale's latest horror that has
a hell of a lot to impact from it
the ending of the film may leave some
viewers scratching their heads
so i thought i'd put together an
explanation to break down everything
that you need to know about the film and
its plot
this is full spoilers ahead so if you
haven't seen the movie yet and don't
want to know what happens at the end
then i highly recommend that you turn
off now
with that out the way i'm definition and
welcome to the channel
where i explain it so you don't have to
okay so here are some
out of context spoilers as your last
warning before you watch this video
anyway us follows the story of adelaide
wilson
who along with the rest of her family
returned to her childhood beach home for
a vacation
adelaide is haunted by nightmares from
her youth and she gets increasingly
worried that something bad is about to
happen to her family
these fears quickly become a reality
when four doppelgangers descend upon her
home one night and throughout the film
they do their best to terrorize the
family whilst the family try and get to
the bottom of the mystery of who they
are adelaide's doppelganger is the
leader and she uses the rest of her
forces to separate the family
and spread them out which involves
several different scenarios and
eventually leads to them discovering
that everyone has a shadow version of
themselves
these shadow people known as the
tethered live underground
eat rabbits and mirror the movements of
those on the surface
it's stated in the film that the
tethered may be part of a government
experiment and whilst it's not detailed
this ties into the overall message of
the film which i'll go into later they
have been put in place to attempt to
reverse the control that those who live
above have over them and instead allow
for the tether to control the people on
the surface
we learn that the tethered have come to
kill their opposites and unite to show
themselves to the world
throughout the film we discover
adelaide's childhood including a time
that she was at a carnival with her
parents
and after wandering into a hall of
mirrors witnessed a mirror version of
herself
this opens the film but we learn a lot
more of this backstory as the movie goes
on it turns out that the beach house is
in the same location that the carnival
was that she visited as a child and the
trauma that she experienced there has
come back in full force to haunt her
though the family managed to kill some
of the tethered upon returning to the
beach the next day they see many of them
holding hands as a symbol of their union
and to show that this is us adelaide's
doppelganger manages to kidnap
adelaide's son and descends into the
subsurface world
adelaide follows her through the hall of
mirrors from her childhood in which we
discover that there's a secret doorway
there
it's here that we learn the truth behind
the movie and it turns out that
adelaide's doppelganger planned the
entire invasion
and has been waiting for 30 years to
spring her trap it appears that adelaide
manages to kill her doppelganger and
rescue her son
however and this is the big twist of the
film we learned that when adelaide
originally met her doppelganger in the
hall of mirrors
they actually switched places this is
why adelaide is the only member of the
tethered that is able to speak
and this also explains her quest for
revenge the doppelganger upon reaching
the surface as a child was able to
adjust over time to normal life but she
still possesses those traumatic memories
the real adelaide has been the one
trapped underground in this drive and
need to return to the surface
is why she began attempting to command
the army of doppelgangers
the twist feels like it was ripped
straight out of the goosebumps book
let's get invisible and those who
remember that episode will of course see
a lot of similarities here
the rest of this video that discusses
the meaning behind the tethered
is something that i've already covered
so if you've seen that video already you
may want to skip certain sections of
this one as it's retreading a lot of old
ground
for those who haven't known stay tuned
as there are a lot of things that we can
take from the director of the film
that signifies the meaning behind the
tethered well jordan peel when speaking
frankly about the creatures
stated the following we're our own worst
enemy
and that idea created this monster the
tethered
i wanted to forge this new mythology
that explored our duality
and the duality of the characters i
think what was a fun challenge for the
actors was finding the connections
between the characters and their
counterparts
at the premiere for the film one
questioned the director said
on the broader strokes of things this
movie is about this country
i was stricken with the fact that we are
in a time where we fear the other
whether it's the mysterious invader that
we think is going to come and kill us
take our jobs or the faction that we
don't live near that vote a different
way than us
we're all about pointing the finger and
i wanted to suggest that maybe the
monster we really need to look at has
our face
maybe the evil is us this makes sense a
lot and though this may be a reach
perhaps the title us isn't just us but
it's actually also
us as in the united states
if correct this could also mean that
perhaps we must look at ourselves to be
positive in order to create a better
world for tomorrow
no this isn't an anti-america hey ran
it's just that perhaps the film is
putting the responsibility on us for
letting the world get to the point that
it is
the scissors too hold their own
significance to peel which conforms to
the overall message of the film
peel also stated when we talk about the
scissors and the rabbits
for every choice like that there are
several different reasons that click to
me but the first
test that anything passed was the genre
test so
does it conjure the horror genre to me
which is a limitation that i feel very
dedicated to working within
i think rabbits and scissors they're
both scary things to me and both
inane things so i love subverting and
bringing out the scariness and things
you wouldn't necessarily associate with
that
this again cements that whilst ghosts
werewolves and more
may be scary on a supernatural level in
real life when compared to the mundane
they are a mere fantasy
this is what's most horrifying about the
tethered they showcase all of the things
that we've tried to push beneath the
surface that will eventually come back
to haunt us
however there are other things that
could be taken from the mysterious
creatures
that perhaps shed a positive light on
them to me they represent
the rising of the oppressed and that
it's now time for those that have been
pushed to the shadows to finally come to
the light and showcase that they are the
majority
rather than the minority there's clear
allusions to the metoo movement of black
lives matter and more and the film is
definitely a commentary on the social
situations that are happening in the
world today
it's quite a nice little metaphor and
whilst i do feel that the film falls
apart slightly in certain areas
the meaning behind it is still strong
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film and if you took anything
different from it
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and make sure you check out my
breakdown of last week's other big movie
captain marvel which will be linked at
the end this is the channel for people
who are mad into movies
so if that's the kind of thing you like
hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this i've been definition
you've been the best and i'll see you
next time take care
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you